people will start a business and they
start to succeed a little bit so they
start to get a little money and then
they hold on to that money because they
remember what it was like being broke
when you hold on to your money that's
your tool and then wonder how do i grow
how do i expand and you're not willing
to let go of the number one tool you
have which is money you want to continue
to use that money and continue to be
willing to lose it all not stupid risks
calculated risks but i'm not afraid to
lose it all because i was broke when i
started i was happy broke i'm happy rich
being broke is hard and making money is
hard pick one